hello everyone i'm simai dolener
studying molecular biology and genetics
at bachelor university in turkey
i'm working as an undergraduate research
assistant in a cancer biology laboratory
focusing on non-small cylon carcinoma
and pancreatic cancer
in vet love and chronic lymphocytic
leukemia in dry lock
we are mainly studying on cell
proliferation and epithelial to medicine
carbon transition
to identify specific genes and pathways
which triggers the cancer progression
during my undergraduate studies i was
having trouble with computational
biology in the means of analysis and
interpretation of the big data
therefore i had to improve my knowledge
and experience in this field because
i was aware of the importance of high
throughput data analysis and the results
obtained
so in order to gain experience and
knowledge i participated to
pine birthday fellowship program and
enrolled as an intern for three months
but i should include that my my
knowledge on bioinformatics was quite
limited and i had some concerns about
whether i would succeed
during this time i took several online
courses
about omix technologies and machine
learning which was a great opportunity
to remember my previous knowledge and
build my
background on bioinformatics moreover
there were hands-on assignments to
practice what we learned
and also several quizzes for each course
to evaluate ourselves and see our
missing points so i can indicate that
courses were very helpful for me because
it was starting with the basic
information
and continuing by increasing the
complexity that enabled me to integrate
multiple perspectives
and also the fields besides i had the
opportunity to participate in several
webinars
and these were very beneficial because
it was showing some glimpses from
diverse research topics
and increasing my curiosity for the
upcoming details having weekly
meetings with our mentors and other
participants were really critical and
important for me because
we were sharing our progress asking our
questions and discussing them together
it was such a positive environment that
when i needed to ask anything in time i
could be able to reach
and get guidance from my advisors
immediately
furthermore there were two huge
opportunities that i can benefit from
the first one is the tibia infraserver
which is the platform that we are using
for processing and
analyzing the data and it's very simple
and enriched with lots of information on
each step
the second one is the codon methodology
platform which explains and shows the
coding but very basic steps
even though coding was quite complex for
me this platform helped me a lot in this
process
so i believe the best side of this
program was to conduct an individual
project
it was a great chance to integrate the
theoretical and the practical part
nearly within the two months i completed
a project
titled identification of lincrnas as
serpentic targets in chromic lymphocytic
leukemia
and my research has just been published
on
columbia undergraduate science journal
so my propose was to identify
possible therapeutic targets to be able
to trigger the spontaneous regression
mechanism
in different cancer types for this i
used an rna-seq dataset from a
bioproject that can be found in ncbi
by using the tibianfo infraserver i
conducted two main analysis
first of all i explored my data and then
i did differential gene expression
analysis between spontaneous regression
and the progressive tumor states to
identify
significantly expressed genes
consequently it revealed that
significant protein coding genes were
correlated with biogenesis and
processing of rna molecules
therefore i investigated the non-coding
genes and found highly expressed
tertiary link rnas
furthermore i identified three novel
link rnas that can be
important in regression mechanism and
can be used as therapeutic targets
but of course these findings can be
confirmed by additional studies
so if you would like to see the outcomes
of this research in a more detailed
manner
i will definitely advise you to check
our recent paper
it was really significant experience for
me to be part of this scientific
environment
and i'm really happy to see the upcoming
events so
thank you so much for this amazing
fellowship
program